شيء مفقود بشكل ملحوظ من
احتفال روسيا اليوم بالانتصار أه
على النازيين إنها القلعة الطائرة
الملقبة بطائرة يوم القيامة cnn's brian todd
هنا مع نظرة فاحصة لنا بريان
كان من المتوقع أن تلعب الطائرة
دورًا بارزًا ولكن تبين أنها لا  أظهر
أن هذا هو الذئب الصحيح أن الكرملين ألغى
هذا الجسر اليوم بسبب مشكلات الطقس.
تمرين
في الأيام الأخيرة على رحلة جوية كان من
المقرر إجراؤها خلال موكب يوم النصر لروسيا ،
لكن هذا العرض تم إلغاؤه اليوم ، ويقول
الكرملين ، مستشهدين بالظروف الجوية ، إن هذا
يعد بمثابة مراوغة معدلة لطائرات النقل ،
لكن ألقابها بما في ذلك
يوم القيامة والكرملين الطائر تحكي
القصة الحقيقية  هذه هي الطائرة الرئيسية
التي تعرفها من أجل قيادتهم
وسيطرتهم  إنها أيضًا الطائرة الرئيسية
بالنسبة لهم في جوهرها لإدارة بلدهم ،
فقد تم تصميم الطائرة لحماية
فلاديمير بوتين في أسوأ الحالات التي
قد تستخدم فيها روسيا
الطائرة للحصول على كل قيادتها
على الأرض ، والغرض الكامل من هذه
الطائرات هو  للحفاظ على هذه القيادة الروسية
آمنة وقابلة للبقاء في حالة حدوث
تبادل نووي محتمل
، لا تحتوي الطائرة الغامضة المعروفة أيضًا باسم max dome
على نوافذ خارجية باستثناء
قمرة القيادة ، وعادةً ما يكون لديك نوافذ في
هذه المناطق هنا ،
هذه النوافذ غير-  موجودون
لأنهم يريدون التأكد من أنه في حالة
حدوث انفجار نووي أنه لا
يوجد أي احتمال على الإطلاق لتحطيم النوافذ ،
يقول المحللون إن طائرة يوم القيامة
هي في الأساس مركز قيادة محمول
جواً مع معدات اتصالات خاصة ،
لذلك يمكن لبوتين إصدار أوامر
بضربات عسكرية.  المنطقة المقببة
هذا هو رادومهم
وقبة اتصالاتهم لهذا يسمح لهم
بالحصول على اتصالات آمنة
يمكن إعادة تزويد الطائرة بالوقود
في جميع الظروف الجوية تقريبًا ، ويقول خبراء الطيران إنه يمنحها
القدرة على البقاء في الجو
لفترات طويلة ، وبحسب ما ورد
لم يُشاهد الكرملين الطائر في موكب يوم النصر
منذ عام 2010 ، ويقول المحللون إن
النية لعرضها  الآن يمكن أن يكون
مؤشرا على إرسال بوتين تحذيرا
إلى الغرب مع احتدام الحرب في أوكرانيا
على استعداد أو إشارة مقترحة
لاستخدام الأسلحة النووية بطريقة تكتيكية
أو جاهزة أكثر مما
نعتقد في الولايات المتحدة ، هناك نسخة أمريكية
من  طائرة يوم القيامة
لحماية الرئيس تسمى المراقبة الليلية e-4b
وهذا الأسطول من
الطائرات هو كما صُممت الطائرات الروسية
للقيام به ، وهو مصمم للقيادة العليا للولايات المتحدة لمواصلة
القيادة والسيطرة على القوات النووية
عند حدوث تصعيد وفي حالة حدوث تصعيد.  من
خبراء هجوم نووي يقولون إن الولايات المتحدة لديها بالفعل أسطولًا
من أربع طائرات يوم القيامة
يقولون إنهم لا يطيرون بشكل روتيني مع
الطائرات  معرف في كل رحلة ولكن
يتم دائمًا تزويد أحدهم بالوقود على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع
للنشر المحتمل في أي مكان في
العالم ، إنه أمر مثير للإعجاب